hallo herzlich willkommen in sallyis
Welt ihr wisst ja dass ich vor kurzem
Backmischungen rausgebracht habe und
diese zwei Sorten gibt's ja gerade
aktuell begrenzt bei Lidl und ich zeige
euch heute dass ihr daraus nicht nur das
machen könnt was auf der Verpackung
steht sondern die auch noch richtig
genial abwandeln könnt ich habe mir
gedacht ich nehme jetzt hier den
vanillkipfall Cheesecake und auch den
Rotweinkuchen ihr könnt den so
zubereiten wie ihr auf der Verpackung
steht aber ihr könnt wie gesagt auch was
geniales anderes draus machen der
Rotweinkuchen den könnt ihr gerne auch
mit Traubensaft zubereiten und ihr ma
meine Community hat mich Tzu dazu
tatsächlich inspiriert heute zu sagen
ich zeige euch auch mal Alternativen ich
mache jetzt hier nämlich aus dem
Rotweinkuchen einen kaffeekuchen der in
einer genialen Backform gebacken wird
mit einer richtig leckeren
Schokoladenglasur ich werde daraus aber
auch XXL streuselmuffins zubereiten und
ich mache daraus noch richtig coole
einfache wopie Pies also Inspiration
Nummer 1 ist Rotweinkuchen aber nicht
als Rotweinkuchen sondern wir machen
daraus einen kaffeekuchen ich nehme
quasi diese Rotwein Backmischung und
dann habe ich außerdem hier
Schokoladenstreusel 50 g Kaffee 100 ml
der ist jetzt auch schon abgekühlt
Butter und Eier und die braucht ihr
sowieso auch für den Kuchen das heißt
hier habe ich 175 g Butter und drei Eier
das war's und dann ebenso wie auf der
Backmischung einfach erstmal die
Backmischung nehmen und mit den
restlichen Zutaten hier verrühren wobei
ich die Streusel erst am Ende dazu gebe
einfach mit dem handrühgerät kurz
anmischen und dann 3 Minuten bei
höchster Stufe cremig rühren
[Musik]
jetzt fettet ihr eure Backform einfach
mit etwas backtrendpray oder weicher
Butter ich habe hier eine
rehrückenbackform ihr könnt natürlich
auch eine Springform nehmen oder auch
eine gogelhupfbackform füllt den Teig
hinein und dann kommt das ganze in den
Backofen gut ich geb zu für die Backform
ist es ein bisschen viel Teig deswegen
mache ich es nicht ganz zu voll der Teig
geht ja noch schön auf und den
restlichen Teig ich lasse dir auch was
übrig zum Schlecken okay aber ich ma
noch ein Tassenkuchen draus ich fül den
Rest noch in Tassenkuchen und D ma noch
[Musik]
Tassenkuchen nach dem backen abkühlen
könnt ihr den Kuchen dann schön auf eine
Platte
stürzen habe ich jetzt schon die
Schokoladenglasur einfach erwärmt und
die kommt auf den Kuchen
drauf
und dann habt ihr hier einen richtig
leckeren saftigen
kaffeekuchen die kriegst du und die
kommt in offen okay
okay ich Katz ger aus ich will nicht
dass es übrig bleibt ich Katze sogar
meine eisportionere aus deswegen muss
auch mit dem Löffel essen mit dem
weil der alles auskratzt ich kratze auch
alle meine Marmeladengläser die
die die Schokoladencreme bon alles wird
ausgekratzt Anna das ist deine Tasse das
ist dein Löffel have fun thank you und
du Tassenkuchen du kommst jetzt in
Ofen vielleicht machen wir sogar
mikrowellenkuchen dusus für die Muffins
nehme ich jetzt hier quasi die
rotweinuchen Mischung ihr nehmt
trauensaft oder Rotwein und dann habe
ich jetzt hier die Streusel nämlich 100
g Mehl 50 g kalte Butter 50 g Zucker
etwas Salz und Zimt und außerdem nehmt
ihr dann noch ein paar Kirschen und
Schokoladenstreusel den Teig stelle ich
gleich her den braucht ihr jetzt nicht
noch mal sehen und die Streusel die
werden einfach so gemacht dass ihr Mehl
Butter Zucker Salz und Zimt einfach kurz
miteinander
[Musik]
verknetet ich mache das ganze jetzt in
der XXL Muffin Form mit diesen süßen
Papierförmchen ihr könnt aber auch
natürlich eine ganz normale Größe nehmen
ich habe für die XXL Form aber auch
einen XXL Eisportionierer falls ihr den
nicht habt nehmt ihr einfach zwei
Eisportionierer voll dann ist es nämlich
perfekt für diese Menge das heißt ich
fülle den Teig ein dann kommen die
Kirschen mit rein etwas Schokostreusel
und dann eben meine Butterstreusel drauf
und dann ab in der Backofen bin mal
gespannt ich glaube aber was schmeckt
richtig gut so bisschen muss ich sagen
so bisschen schwarzwäer kirscheart mit
[Musik]
Streusel
Kirschen die drücke ich jetzt gleich
noch so bisschen rein am besten mit der
Gabel dann verteilt sich es ganz
[Musik]
gut okay es wird auch die Hälfte der
Streusel und die Hälfte der
Schokostreusel reichen ich geb es euch
im Blog und in der App in der richtigen
Menge an und die Menge ist für Anna ich
würde jetzt einfach behaupten ich habe
doppelt so viel gemacht D du was
hast ich liebe streudel so ab in
Backofen würde ich mal
[Musik]
sagen und so sehen jetzt die fertigen
XXL Muffins aus sie riechen gut sie
sehen Top aus ich finde die sehen aus
wie auf dem aus dem Kaffeehaus wie
gekauft ich zeig euch hier mal einen und
die sind so weich so
luftig machen wir mal zusammen auf
hier guckt euch das mal
an ich probi den jetzt nicht weil ich ja
schon sehe rieche und höre wie gut er
ist
oh mein Gott die kommenbi so lecker ich
probiere eigentlich nur nicht weil er
gleich noch fotografiert wird aber komm
so ein Stück einmal ans Fototeam und
bitte wieder vollständig zurück ja okay
dürft euch alle
[Musik]
einnehmen für die wopiis habe ich den
Teig jetzt hier vorbereitet und nehme
den mittleren Eisportionierer also die
zweite Größe setzt die Teigbällchen hier
drauf mit etwas Abstand und dann kommen
sie in den Backofen und in der
Zwischenzeit kann ich hierfür schon mal
eine Creme zubereiten entweder eine
Sahnecreme eine Quarkcreme eine
Buttercreme alles was euch
[Musik]
schmeckt die wopie Pie sind gerade noch
im Ofen aber ich habe noch ein bisschen
Teig übrig und ich dachte mir ich nehme
jetzt einfach meine Mini burgerringe und
mach noch eine minitorte so eine kleine
süße Geburtstagstorte oder auch eine
Torte zum
[Musik]
Verschenken die wopiees sind gebacken
und abgekühlt ihr könnt sie jetzt wie
gesagt mit einer Creme füllen oder auch
mit Eiscreme ich nehme jetzt einfach
Eiscreme dafür und dann packe ich zwei
zusammen als Sandwich mach sie noch mal
ins Kühlfach als küler und tauche sie
dann in die Glasur die ich hier in der
Backmischung auch dabei habe und dann
kommen erst die schreusel drauf dann
habe ich nämlich icecream wy
[Musik]
Pies hab hier die wopi P und die werden
jetzt zur Hälfte eingetaucht
schockerstreusel drauf
fertig
[Musik]
guckt mal richtig schön ganz tolle
icecream
Sandwiches für die miniörtchen nehme ich
jetzt hier die Creme aus meinem
vanillkipfall Cheesecake ihr könnt
nämlich auch rotweinkuchenbackmischung
und vanillekip Cheesecake einfach
kombinieren deswegen mache ich jetzt die
miniörtchen damit denn das ist eine
richtig leckere cheesecakeceme einfach
mit Frischkäse und Sahne jeweils 400 g
verrühren kurz und dann auf höchster
Stufe eine Minute
[Musik]
aufschlagen habe ich hier die
Tortenböden ich habe sie auch schon mal
durchgeschnitten und Fülle jetzt die
Torte bzw das Törtchen mit der Creme F
mal das Törtchen mit Creme an Mund
auf ach
komm ich eine Lochtülle damit mache ich
jetzt hier weil es naked cake wird naked
[Musik]
Törtchen und jetzt kommt hier in die
Mitte die Glasur die habe ich bereits
erwärmt die gibt's ja auch in der
rotweinuchenmischung jetzt noch zwei
gefrier getrocknete himbn drüber und die
Geburtstagskerze ich hole mein
busenbrenner ist das süß so mega süß wem
schenke ich die denn jetzt schenk sie
mir selber liebe s ich wünsche dir alles
Liebe und Gute für die Zukunft und euch
allen auch allen Menschen die dieses
Video schauen ich wünsche uns allen
Glück Gesundheit und immer Menschen die
euch glücklich machen und Kraft
schenken geht wohl in Erfüllung also
jetzt habt ihr gesehen aus einer
Rotweinkuchen Backmischung habe ich drei
nein sogar vier verschiedene Dinge draus
gezaubert die eigentlich nicht erahnen
lassen dass es eine Backmischung ist die
Backmischungen gibt's jetzt aktuell wie
gesagt noch bei Lidl nur für kurze Zeit
und ich finde alle vier Ideen cool ihr
könnt ja gerne mal in die Kommentare
schreiben was euch von den vier Ideen am
besten gefallen hat und mir fällt jetzt
gerade noch spontan ein schreibt doch
gerne in die Kommentare was man noch
draus zubereiten könnte vielleicht mache
ich ja noch ein Video draus und ich
würde sagen alle die mitmachen die
gewinnen dann
ein überraschungsbackpaket von mir
schreibt's gerne rein ich bin gespannt
drauf wir freuen uns jedenfalls jetzt
drauf alles zu probieren und alles zu
essen alles sieht wunderschön aus und es
hat richtig viel Spaß gemacht weil es
einfach so mega kreativ war also viel
Spaß beim backen viel Spaß beim
Anschauen viel Spaß beim Kommentieren
und viel Glück beim genspiel bis zum
nächsten
Mal